- [Kelly] So, your family was so cute
when they watched you win gold in Tokyo.
I can only imagine.
So, who had the best
reaction when you got home?
- I think definitely my sister.
She's been like my best friend.
Of course I was super
excited to see my dad
and my mom,
because they have basically supported me
throughout the whole thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was so excited to wrap the medals
around their neck,
but I think just being with my sister
was like the most amazing thing,
because she's my best friend.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's amazing!
(audience clapping)
How far apart are you on age?
- We are actually a week and a half apart.
She's my step-sister,
but we're...
- I was like...
I wish you could have
been in my head just then.
I was like, "Wait, what?"
(guest giggles)
I was like (indistinct)
Oh, that's amazing!
- Yeah! So, we're really close.
- Hey! Blended families
are hard sometimes,
so, that's amazing
you're all are so close.
That's cool.
- We used to hate each other
when we were younger.
- [Kelly] See? That happens.
(audience laughing)
You know what?
Thank you though, I have young kids,
they hate each other sometimes,
and I'm like, "You're
going to like each other,
"one day, right?"
- Yeah! Yeah!
- [Kelly] Okay, cool.
(guest giggling)
Yeah! So, do you have any rituals
before you compete?
- I have to get ready,
like two hours earlier.
I have to listen to the same song.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
You're like my sister in an airport.
(guest giggles)
She used to be there like forever before.
- I know and I'm usually always late so...
- [Kelly] Okay.
Well, what song do you listen to
before you compete?
I get like amped up before my shows
- Same, it's always like rap
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Oh my God! That is so funny,
I love the most opposite of me.
I'm like, "Yes Jay-Z!
"I'm ready!"
I'm amped up.
There's something about the beat.
Like all their beats.
- It just makes you like,
so hyped before you go.
This is exactly what I need
- [Kelly] Yeah!
Yes, absolutely.
Do you do any ritual before you act,
or anything?
- Well, music is always a way in for me.
I always make a playlist
for my characters.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that!
- Yup! Yup! Yup!
- [Kelly] That's smart.
Because it does get you in the mood.
- Totally.
Totally.
- That's clever.
- Yup!
- [Kelly] Everyone's
stealing that idea right now.
(audience laughs)
- Okay.
So you're on "Dancing with the Stars" now,
and there's a history of elite athletes
like winning.
Do you think it's unfair
'cause you're so athletic,
like going against people
that are maybe similar
to how in shape I am?
- Okay, really?
(everybody laughing)
- But dancing is different.
- Yeah! And the whole cast though,
I feel like is dancers.
So, everybody kind of has experience,
but...
- [Kelly] Okay.
- The most dancing I do is on the floor,
when I'm trying to distract
everybody and myself
from thinking about landing on my face.
(Kelly laughing)
So, I don't know.
Like it's just very different.
I never had dance class,
but it's been really fun lately.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
You feel confident as a dancer?
Like, when you're out there?
I sometimes on stage
become like this super confident person.
Like, I'm a confident person in life,
but I feel like when you're on stage,
and you're like doing stuff,
you feel like, "I'm Jay-Z".
- [Guest] No.
I'm so nervous.
(everyone laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh you do?
- Yes.
I mean when I'm competing for gymnastics,
I'm completely fine,
but this is like something
I'd never done before.
So, when I'm doing it,
I'm like, "Oh my God!"
I'm shaking and stuff in the back.
But I feel like I also just stress,
because I like,
don't practice enough,
because gymnastics I'm used to practicing
like seven hours.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is like three hours.
- That sounds like workout though.
(guests laughing)
That sounds hard.
I love that you get nervous,
so, that's good that
you're telling us that,
because we just think of you as like,
superheroes and you do anything
and you're fine all the time.
So, you get nervous with it?
That makes me feel good.
- [Guest] Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- I feel better now.
I'm sorry for you.
- Usually, I have to
puke every time before
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
That's so horrible.
(everyone laughing)